I'm an thornton's provost and university
librarian at columbia university
libraries and it's my pleasure to
welcome all of you here tonight in 2008
the normani alexander foundation
generously donated four million dollars
to columbia university libraries to hire
a jewish studies librarian and to
support collections and jewish studies
thanks to the continued support of Gale
bender minh and the alexander foundation
columbia university libraries has become
internationally known for its jewish
studies collections we participate in
local and global partnerships in Jewish
Studies librarianship and are very proud
of the work that we have done as just a
few examples we were partners with New
York University the New York Public
Library tel Aviv University and the
National Library of Israel in making
important early Jewish early newspapers
from the american jewish press freely
available to the public we have just
completed initial digitization on a
massive archive documenting yiddish
linguistics and we are about to complete
a project to catalog all of our rare
hebrew imprints in clio Columbia's
online catalog none of these projects or
the many other jewish studies related
projects at the library would have been
possible without the normani alexander
foundation the annual normani alexander
lecture celebrates the Alexander
Foundation's great gift to us and
demonstrates our commitment to
supporting the field of jewish studies
at Columbia for many years to come and
now it's my pleasure to introduce
Michelle chaz nur the normani alexander
librarian for jewish studies thank you
in before i start i'm just going to ask
that everybody turned their cell phones
off or silence them and welcome
it was silence your cell phone Jenna
Weissman Jocelyn is the charles e smith
professor of jewish studies and
professor of history at the George
Washington University where she also
created and now directs to graduate
programs in Jewish culture and the arts
the first of their kind in the country
dr. Weissman Jocelyn is the author among
other things of the wonders of America
which received the National Jewish Book
Award in history and of the critically
acclaimed a perfect fit clothes
character and the promise of America she
also writes a monthly column for the
forward newspaper which is just about to
enter its 18th consecutive year of
publication her latest book set in stone
America's embrace of the Ten
Commandments will be published in the
spring in addition to teaching and
writing Jenna Weissman joseline has
enjoyed an active career as a museum
curator and consultant her most recent
exhibition Shalom bias reflections on
the American Jewish home is on view at
the Yiddish book center in Amherst a
former senior fellow at Princeton Center
for the Study of American religion on
whose academic advisory board she sits
joseline has also been a fellow at
Michigan's Franco Institute pen Centre
for the event for advanced judaic
studies and Yale Center for American Art
and material culture most recently she
has been a distinguished visiting
scholar at the Library of Congress's
John W Kluge Center so it is my great
pleasure to welcome Jenna Weissman
Jocelyn good evening everyone thank you
ever since Moses came down from the
mountain with the Ten Commandments in
tow these divine prescriptions have
exercised the collective imagination
everyone historians clergy literary
critics novelists psychotherapists and
politicians everyone has had something
to say about them my bookshelves and I
imagine yours as well sag under the
weight of so much commentary especially
when for good
measure you throw in the vast and
steadily growing literature on the First
Amendment and the nettlesome
relationship between church and state
much of this literature is well known
perhaps even familiar but now and again
you happen across the text that
occasions another look at the Ten
Commandments a deepening of perspective
a sharpening of critical engagement this
evening I'd like to talk about two such
publications all with an eye towards
understanding how it came to pass that
the Ten Commandments captured and
enlivened the American imagination the
first text I'd like to share with you is
not much to look at the whole thing
which dates to 1860 runs to no more than
13 pages the paper on which it's printed
is inexpensive the typography
rudimentary when I consulted the text
several years ago in the rare book room
of the New York Public Library the
composition was so fragile and brittle
that crumbs of paper littered the table
every time I turned its pages but then I
have a sneaking suspicion that even in
its prime the condition of the text was
not much better the entire assemblage
looks as if it's held together by
spit-and-polish like its physical
armature the literary sensibility of
this 1860 publication also leaves a lot
to be desired opaque dense hard to
follow the composition sinks under the
weight of detail and a torrent of words
the steadying hand of an editor is
nowhere in evidence still for all its
shortcomings this text from 1860 packs a
wallop it's loosely bound pages tell one
hell of a story the discovery of an
ancient relic containing the text of the
Ten Commandments a discovery made not in
the holy land or an ancient Egypt but in
Ohio
the volume is called a representation of
the two stones with the characters
inscribed upon them that were found by
dy Rick during the summer of 1860 not a
very inspiring title its author d or
david weirich was a retired surveyor of
the county of licking ohio his neighbors
thought him a simple-minded earnest man
of the people of ordinary capacity why
Rick believed that the area's array of
Indian earthworks its monstrous stone
mounds was the handiwork of the Ten Lost
Tribes to back up his belief why work
spent many of his waking hours
excavating these thousand year old
Indian burial mounds they were so
plentiful in his part of the country
that it came to be known as Ohio's very
own Valley of the Kings why Rick's
steadfastness paid off when in November
1860 his Spade hit something hard a
small stone casket in which reposed a
second lithic object said to be a
peculiar shape and dark color measuring
sixth and seventh eighth inches long two
and seventh eighth inches wide and one
and five eight inches thick it
reportedly bore a strong resemblance to
a plain round topped church window but
everything else about the stone was
unusual one side contained an incised
likeness of a turban and tunic clad
gentlemen of decidedly oriental and
truculent appearance or so we're told
the figure sported a neatly trimmed
beard and clutched an arch-shaped tablet
to his breast the other side of the
stone was covered from top to bottom in
what appeared to be and was later
confirmed as Hebrews script running
every which way and into one another the
letters came together to form the text
of the Ten Commandments a slightly
abridged version to be sure and one
riddled with spelling mistakes to boot
but an unmistakable version of this
text all the same news of wyrex
discovery spread quickly electrifying
the imagination and generating
considerable excitement if this is
authentic declared the Cincinnati Daily
Inquirer it ranks among the most
important discoveries of the kind ever
made upon this continent added Reverend
mr miller of seneca ville ohio why works
find soon to be known far and wide as
the decalogue or holy stone furnished
incontestable proof said he that the
sons of jacob were walking on the soil
of ohio many centuries before the birth
of Columbus here Miller said here are
Hebrew letters and words and sentences
and law brought out from the depths of
these mounds these letters are not
syriac or arabic egyptian or chinese
they are Hebrew and Hebrews must have
placed them where we find them in short
order the Decalogue stone was
photographed sketched traced and cast in
plaster so that its likeness could be
widely circulated studied and even made
available for autopsy as one interested
party would have it what's more in a
rather startling departure from current
scholarly protocol why Rick agreed to
part company with his precious find long
enough for the learned men of the
American ethnological society to see for
themselves what all the fuss was about
handling this object turning it this way
and that the organization's members
train their sights on the script whose
lettering did not resemble any Hebrew
characters they had previously
encountered with its unfamiliar ly
shaped olive la mode and I on what kind
of Hebrew could this possibly be vast
themselves avidly discussing the finer
points of a pig raphy well I know my
olives said one scholar and I've never
seen an olive like this one my Hebrew
the stone date then to pre excellent
times could it be the hand said one of a
proselyte of some long past age
imperfectly instructed in the Hebrew
religion perhaps the work of a plebeian
an uneducated Hebrew when I plowed
through these accounts awash in the
technicalities of orthographic detail
and the Arcana of archeology my eyes
glazed over but why Rick's
contemporaries couldn't get enough the
press from the Ohio farmer and the New
York evangelist to the ladies repository
and the oxidant and American Jewish
advocate obliged filling column after
column of newsprint with information
about the physical dimensions in
cultural import of why Rick's find
meanwhile a steady round of lectures fed
the public's appetite for more getting
to the bottom of what the New York Times
called one of the greatest problems that
has ever been Willard the American
historian had much to do with the
attention why Rick's discovery received
who built the stone heaps who are the
earliest inhabitants or aboriginals of
the new world these were questions of
long standing and so why works discovery
was the latest and for a few months at
least seemingly the most definitive
development in a continuously unfolding
story that dated to the early years of
the Republic when Americans first looked
to the past into the soil to establish
an ancient pedigree when it came to the
identity of the mound billers
speculation had been rife reported the
Washington star understating the
complexity of the situation but no more
the Decalogue stone and the site from
whence it came deep within an ancient
stone mound provided a welcome measure
of closure does this not appear very
Jewish does it not look very much like
the act of Joshua who wrote upon the
stones a copy of the laws of Moses does
this not furnish us with strong grounds
for the belief that our mouths
the builders were Jews surmised Isaac
Schmucker a founding father of the town
of Newark Ohio and like why rukh a firm
believer in the Ten Lost Tribes theory
of origin from his perspective nothing
more effectively shored up the antiquity
of the United States than the discovery
of the Ten Commandments that age old
covenant between the Jews and their God
nestled within the bosom of a hoary
burial mound but not everyone was
convinced for each American who saluted
its authenticity an equal number of
citizens believed the ancient relic to
be pure bunk an artifact of artifice
rather than of history perhaps even a
college prank allegations of anat this
inauthenticity flew fast and furious
these Ten Commandments charged the
dubious minded was nothing but an
out-and-out scam a work of religious
hocus-pocus it ranked at the time as one
of the three most remarkable forgeries
in the entire history of archaeology one
witty critic put it even more
effectively toying with his generations
fondness for taxonomy he suggested that
why Rick's treasures were best
classified as genus bug species hum amid
the drumbeat of criticism and what some
of Y Rik's champions took to be the
relentless maltreating that fell upon
his unhappy head the amateur
archeologist came to regret having
recovered the object in the first place
the Hebrew stone I fear has done the
evil I wish to God someone else had
found it than myself why Rick wrote
plaintively in 1863 to John Henry the
Secretary of the Smithsonian Institution
and a longtime champion of north
american archaeology someone someone
cried wyrick someone has been trying to
hoax me the distant heart disheartened
digger might
hoped that pointing the finger at a
mysterious someone might clear his name
and in the process resolve the matter of
the stones so-called genuine ship once
and for all but that was not to be left
to his own devices why Rick put pen to
paper and publishing the results at his
own expense mounted a defense of his
actions although his text rambles and
its pros is dry opaque and really hard
to follow there's no mistaking the
passion that guided his hand and
painstaking detail punctuated by a
series of wood cuts he attempted to set
the record straight he wrote it took
three of us working hard from early in
the morning to nearly three o'clock in
the afternoon to reach the clay bed with
a sufficient removal of the detritus to
affect the examination desired an
equally fine grain translation of the
truncated Hebrew text of the Ten
Commandments followed and on its heels a
rhetorical question designed to lay to
rest the possibility that david weirich
a man of truly humble gifts was capable
of a hoax of this magnitude would it not
require a very profound scholar in
hebrew to make such an abridgment of the
hebrew decalogue with foreign characters
as is made above he said by no stretch
of the imagination did the retired
surveyor of licking county fit the bill
for the end said he all the jackknives
in Christendom even in Ohio couldn't
possibly produce such an outrage or a
piece of scholarship the Ten
Commandments relic just had to be real
why work speed for acceptance stood
little to salvage his reputation he died
a few years later in 1964 his name
having become a byword for archeological
chicanery some believe that a despairing
wyrick took his own life others that he
had succumbed to the pernicious effects
of too much laudanum which he had taken
over the years to alleviate the painful
symptoms
of a chronic illness one way or another
the holy stone had done him in along
with the truth was this simple minded
earnest man of the people a dupe had his
unwavering commitment to the so-called
Jewish theory of American history had it
rendered him a pawn in someone else's
scheme a number of contemporaries
certainly third slot so we are bound to
believe that in this manner he has been
and is a victim and not a victimizer
Harper's Weekly grudgingly conceded in
the wake of having harpooned wyrick and
his find but other equally reputable
voices were not so quick to let him off
the hook the discovery in Y Rick's
workshop of a Hebrew Bible as well as a
set of chisels and some say even bits of
slate with snippets of Hebrew carving
that called to mind a practice exercise
these discoveries led his critics to
insist that it was the man from Ohio and
not some other who had fashioned the Ten
Commandments in the first place what
render is why were expelling especially
fascinating is not so much the various
theories that attend its origins or its
meaning but was what was not said about
it near as I can tell no one no one
batted an eye at its contents nary a
soul not even the most hardened of
doubting Thomases wondered why hoaxer no
hoax the biblical passages that had to
do with the Ten Commandments rather than
some others were showcased in the first
place the issue simply didn't come up it
strained no ins credulity over text no
one's imagination or flummoxed anyone in
the least that the text of the Decalogue
happened to materialize in Ohio one fine
fall day on the eve of the Civil War at
the time people accepted or questioned
the aged pneus of the stones patina the
antiquity of its inscriptions and the
skill with which truculent moses was
depicted but no one no one had anything
what to say about its subject matter it
was almost as if geology had trumped
reason the stone eNOS of the original
biblical Ten Commandments presaging and
legitimating the stone eNOS of this one
bound together by their sturdy
materiality by their stolidity these two
deco logs went from the old world and
the other from the new stood for
something immutable elemental and
interconnected the fullest expression of
the imperishable then again it didn't
take much for wire works contemporaries
to embrace the notion that a pre
excellent version of the Ten
Commandments had washed up on their
Shores by the time he announced his
thrilling discovery Americans throughout
the country had taken the biblical do's
and don'ts to heart rooting them as much
in the American psyche as in its
landscape swept along by the current of
enthusiasm for Moses a lionized American
hero whose transformation of a ragtag
bunch of folks into a disciplined
community bound by law was widely
believed to parallel the nation's very
own history the Ten Commandments then
were heralded as an American phenomenon
through and through the Decalogue
rhapsodize rabbi isaac mayor wise
another ohioan the decalogue he said was
the very first declaration of
independence the first proclamation of
Liberty the first and eternal blast from
the trumpet of freedom unless anyone
missed the connection between Mount
Sinai and America rabbi wise elaborated
louder and mightier yet resounded that
one great and powerful word of the
Almighty which is freedom freedom
freedom what American would argue with
that or would want to if you were
determined to establish a national
identity especially one burnished by a
distinguished pedigree there happened to
be no better text on which to hang
than the Ten Commandments in one fell
swoop it assembled the rule of law the
Word of God and the promise of election
joining them together in the vision of
an ancient past and the prospect of a
glorious future and all under the banner
of indigenous pneus the Ten Commandments
you see just happened to be the perfect
foundational document the second text
I'd like to share with you runs 2 202
pages and also bears a rather
nondescript title it's called Moses in
Egypt the documentation to the motion
picture the Ten Commandments published
by the university of southern california
press in 1956 and festooned with
footnotes this book seems to be a work
of scholarship it's not despite its
pedigree Moses in Egypt was the
handiwork of Henry Nordlinger one of
Cecil B DeMille right-hand men under his
supervision thousands of facts were
marshaled to establish the credentials
of the ten commandments that Technicolor
blockbuster a post-war America 10 years
in the planning and five years in the
making the Ten Commandments gave new
meaning to epic a colossal undertaking
from start to finish the statistically
intimidating production was said to have
employed 15,000 people at a time among
them hordes of extras many of them local
Egyptians passing as ancient Israelites
The New Yorker for its part suggested
the production encompassed more living
things than the entire population of
Moses's Egypt the film drew on scale
pyrotechnics and history to comment on
and deepen the immense hole that Moses
the Exodus and the giving of the Ten
Commandments had long exerted on
American culture the immensity of the
production was sufficient to compel
Americans to take a second look people
beasts pageantry scenery costumes
jewelry all of this tumble
that you as from a cornucopia exclaimed
father James Fenland Finley all atwitter
at the 16 sphinxes and towering arches
some reaching as high as 100 feet that
lined the way to pharaoh's court
arguably the largest construction
project in egypt since the Suez Canal
the newly fashioned Egyptian city
outside of Luxor even boasted its own
trio of pyramids obviously related a
visitor to the set DeMille was thinking
big and that was just the half of it the
star-studded cast added to the
razzle-dazzle a who's who of stage and
screen it featured yul brenner Vincent
Price sir Cedric Hardwicke edward g
robinson and Dame Judith Anderson who
has the doleful memnet was the possessor
of ominous secrets chewing the scenery
the cast also filled several of its
scenes on location where amidst the vast
expanse of the desert and the stony arid
seemingly immutable landscape that
expression accrued a new meaning we
rolled our cameras from Gaussian to the
Red Sea then across the wilderness of
sure down through the wilderness of sin
and up the steep barren majestic on
inspiring slopes of Mount Sinai to the
holy ground where Moses stood to receive
the law DeMille animatedly recounted as
if he had personally experienced the
exodus from Egypt and stood at Sinai to
back home on the Paramount lot the
filmmaker and his crew up the ante by
making use of the latest technology from
glowing Technicolor to the singular
talents of the studio's special effects
Department ensuring that Reds were never
richer and blues never brighter
simulating the crossing of the Red Sea
by means of hydraulic equipment capable
of spilling 300,000 gallons of water in
two minutes flat sun rising the voice of
God by recording and then slowing down
in actors words until they seemed like
vibrations from some other world
heightening a sense of tension and for
Bodeen by making use of the theremin a
spooky ghostly sounding electronic
instrument filling the screen with a
sickly green vapor that put audiences in
mind of radioactivity all the tricks of
the trade were deployed to animate the
drama that lay at the heart of the
biblical account authenticity the third
and arguably the most fascinating
element on which the Ten Commandments
pivoted Allied scale and technology with
history or more to the point with the
process of transmission cutting a vivid
swath through Old Testament country
DeMille insisted that every aspect of
his film from its color palette to its
sound be as authentic as historically
true as rooted in the sources as
possible you are to invent nothing out
of your own talented imaginations he
charged his team of screenwriters
prompting one of them to observe that
working on this picture was more akin to
a detective investigation than the
composing of a screenplay the efforts of
de Milles team to ensure that every
single detail was based as they put it
on actuality are within probability of
actuality their efforts led them to
consult 950 books 984 periodicals 1286
clippings and 2964 photographs filling
the pages of the book Moses in Egypt
with abundant to tail at first blush the
film's display of bibliographic
extravagance paralleled its visual
extravagance the first read is an
extension of the second yet another form
of showmanship I'm closer reflection the
two made for awfully strange bedfellows
where feature films are typically an
exercise of the imagination non-fiction
books are typically an exercise in
scholarship fact in fancy don't usually
go hand in hand but DeMille made sure
they did transforming history into a
special effect every bit is dazzling
lating and his audience pleasing as more
traditional forms of cinematic wizardry
under northlanders direction the film's
production team consulted everything
Egyptian wall paintings in biblical
illustrations 19th century ordnance
surveys of the Sinai Peninsula and the
latest archaeological discoveries from
Qumran reading and rereading their Bible
as well as Boober and Freud breasted and
Kenyon on Moses in the ancient Near East
they looked these authoritative texts
for information for guidance on how to
build the film set stress the actors
choreograph their movements outfit their
steeds across the Red Sea and receive
the Ten Commandments no detail was too
small or too ethnographic what kinds of
tents did the ancient Israelites inhabit
answer those still in practical use
among the tent dwellers of Arabia what
kinds of colors to the ancient
Israelites fancy answer the tribe of
Reuben was partial to red the followers
of Naphtali preferred wine colored hues
while those who clustered under the
banner of Benjamin liked all colors
combined how did egyptians move what
kinds of musical instruments do they
play do they eat roast beef or lamb
chops or what you have to wonder whether
all this scholarship was merely a
promotional tool designed to woo
moviegoers at a time when film was fast
losing ground to television or maybe it
was a way to face down critics so that
is one of their number put it when wise
guys make fun of the ballet in Pharaoh's
court DeMille calmly refers them to an
ancient Egyptian mural which shows every
movement to be authentic there's no
question that DeMille and his team of
publicists thinking strategically about
how best to promote the film harnessed
history and geography to public
relations claims that the Ten
Commandments brings Sinai to viewers
back home and that when you see the Red
Sea it is the Red Sea were hard to be
as was zippers sweeping assertion that
with the help of Cecil B DeMille we were
there when the Lord handed Moses the Ten
Commandments it was also the case that
DeMille unequivocally believed that his
beloved film stayed true to the facts
and that what others might dub an active
interpretation was actually a way to
fill in the lacuna and the historical
record not mess with them then again
America's number-one film producer and
director could not afford to get things
wrong fiddling with the facts was not an
option the stakes were too high there is
he said there is no place for the usual
fiction in a picture that deals with the
interpretations and circumstances from
which not one but three of the world's
great religions have sprung DeMille
might have added that given the
well-publicized advances in Biblical
Archaeology since the interwar years as
well as increasing opportunities to
visit the Middle East American audiences
were much better informed about that
part of the world than they had ever
been meanwhile the eruption of the Suez
Canal crisis which had taken place only
a few short weeks before the release of
the Ten Commandments had once again
thrust Egypt in Israel into the
limelight and what was an uncanny
coincidence a marvelous accident of
timing at least as far as Hollywood was
concerned the film made its debut
against the raw news of modern conflict
between Israel and Egypt a conflict
excitedly related the New York Times a
conflict that has its preamble in the
book of Exodus DeMille turned out to
have been right audiences for the most
part responded enthusiastically to the
film's distinctive mix of history and
hokum of Scripture and spectacle they
greeted the film with open arms the high
and the mighty the lowly and the meek as
well as those not unanimously do mill
minded reported the motion picture
Herald took to the movie so
well-received was the
10 commandments that within a year of
its debut it had played to an estimated
20 1.9 million people grossing over 26
million dollars in revenue paramount
officials reported one gleeful employee
almost run out of zeroes when they
project its eventual earnings some
moviegoers found the Ten Commandments in
adjunct and a comfort to faith or so
they told the New York Times others
relished its contribution to the
furtherance of so-called Community
Relations values and still others
especially the members of the Women's
League for conservative judaism who
bestowed their annual Torah award under
mill delighted in the way it exemplified
as they put it the richness of the
American tradition how it advanced
Brotherhood and focused the eyes and
ears of the world a mankind's most
magnificent moment bearing the weight of
such high-minded expectations the Ten
Commandments became a singular
expression of Americana the two texts
we've just encountered couldn't be more
different one from the other the first
dated to the eve of the Civil War the
second emerged nearly a century later in
response to the Cold War one was the
handiwork of a single individual of
decidedly modest means and limited
intellectual ambitions the other the
handiwork of an expansive team of
researchers had the backing of a major
corporation and have a man known as mr.
movies still what unites them is far
greater than their respective
differences for one thing both texts
took their cue from history why Rick
coached his fidelity to history in
geological terms Nordlinger expressed
his through documentation bound together
by the weight of the past by the long
shadow cast by the Ten Commandments the
two compositions reflected the nation's
fascination with the biblical text and
its ongoing relevance
to modern America for another thing both
were exercises in apologetics why were
expanded was designed to justify his
archaeological find and to protect his
reputation normal angers tone was
intended to justify the cinematic
enterprise of which he was a vital part
and to protect de Milles good name then
again the Ten Commandments needed no
apology or safeguarding in the new world
they stood tall and whole a vibrant
assertive presence conferring confidence
in authority their combination of
discipline and agency of responsibility
and possibility held out the very real
promise of order and stability in their
formulation of the ties that bound the
individual and the community the Ten
Commandments provided the structure in
which freedom might flourish he had
god's word on that thank you happy to
take questions comments reminiscences
about deville tamils 56 film anything
yes sir thank you thank you for a
wonderful talk I've seen the Ten
Commandments a couple times and what I
remember about it that struck me was the
in the bibliographical richness of the
credits yet it listed the philosopher
Philo of Alexandria who I'm a great fan
of and have never seen listed in movie
credits so I was kind of thrilled to see
the name there but he lists him as a
historian and I would have listed him as
a philosopher but that just to see him
up there at all was kind of a thrill so
so I add my name to that list of people
who are kind of grateful for the movie
and your talk about it i should add that
another thing vector mill added to the
list of credits and imagine imagine this
as the credits are scrolling on down
there's Philo and there's the holy
scriptures and this and and there's
Midrash it's like the first time in the
history of
midrash was put up on the screen and you
had to give DeMille a lot of credit for
that because I think the vast majority
of audiences would take a look at that
word Midrash and say what's that you
know but Midrash apparently played a
great deal of cultural weight in de
Milles thinking about the movie the big
mystery for me is how did he even know
about Midrash or thought Midrash as it's
called and if anybody has a suggestion
i'm eager to to hear how DeMille DeMille
who is the son of a Protestant clergymen
and and Midrash was not banded about
back then in the 50s as it is today it's
not taught in a comp lit class so how
did he know about it you know so but
thank you for that and yes information
about the stone that was original is
there any more information of the stone
that was originally yes over the place
yes so you can actually see the stone
for yourself all you have to do is go to
coshocton ohio small town in Ohio where
there's a museum called the Johnson
Holbrook house an on display in the
Johnson hamrick house is the stone as
well as a number of other goodies that
wyrick managed to uncover and what's
wonderful about that is that the museum
which like a local history museum is not
passing judgment on the veracity or the
lack of veracity of the object but
instead using it as an opportunity to
tell a story about Central Ohio which I
think it's a really interesting
interpretive strategy it's also
sponsored all manner of symposia about
this and so theories keep on coming
about how old it really is you know that
we have the latest technological devices
to uncover the past there are all these
new theories speculative theories but
the best thing is that if you actually
want to purchase a copy of the stone you
can the the gift shop has one for 57
bucks so you too can have your very own
version of the wyrick stone so it still
exists yes yeah oh come on any other
questions comments yeah
what I was that wonderful isn't the
don'ts wonderful yeah so a number of
years ago I was teaching at Princeton
and I was teaching a seminar on America
and the Ten Commandments and I was
encouraging my students to think
visually about the Ten Commandments and
then one of my wonderful students went
home to California for break and she
returned with this thing this drawing
which was a family members rendition of
the Ten Commandments and I'm not sure
he's probably a lot older Eli the author
the illustrator is probably a lot older
and I'm pretty sure would be apt to
disavow his collection of doubts but I
just I was so marvelous the idea of the
Ten Commandments an opportunity for
storytelling especially on the part of a
of a kid I just that was great yeah
thank you here talk so the first example
not only occurs right before the Civil
War but I think at the peak of the
Second Great Awakening and the second
one of course in the face of God most
communism so I'm wondering if you can
talk about what these examples tell us
about the state of religion in America
at that particular time yeah so I think
the the Ten Commandments does a lot of
work you know what we call cultural work
and it at times of really profound
instability offers an opportunity to
think about the possibility of stability
so I think that it's no coincidence that
this is found I would even say that the
signal historical event is more the
breakup of the Union than it is any
internal religious upheaval so clearly
that was a time of great rupture and
again post-war is also a time of great
dislocation and so I think the 10
commandments are very handy they come
into being as a weight a really
wonderful way a counter-narrative to all
that instability
so I think that's part of their their
promise I don't know if that makes sense
I think also when you think about the
wyrick stones they really come on the
heels of the discovery of the Mormon
treasures and so there's some very
pronounced belief in that as one of my
sources put it in the fertility of the
Midwestern mind in its belief that the
soil is so rich with all of these
indigenous forms of religious behavior
of religious belief so I think that also
plays a part I don't know if that's
what's getting at it but I think that
there's something that's very pleasing
about the ten commands you also have to
think about it as something that's
increasingly an American rather than a
denominational what formulation it's up
until recently it was very widespread
and its appeal and all sorts of
different faith communities claimed it
as their own so I think it's probably
and you'll tell me if I'm wrong it's
probably one of the few things that Jews
and Christians historically have in
common and so it just lends itself to
this articulation of sheridan asst I
think that good question yeah I I have a
question about what kind of the last
thing you mentioned about Cecil DeMille
and Midrash I don't know if there's any
evidence that he actually read this work
but wouldn't Louis Ginsburg's the
legends of the Jews have been the most
accessible format for ya midrash in
English right Ike I take your point I'm
not sure that he read it but whoever was
helping him think through or at least
credential eyes the movie new of Midrash
and probably knew of Ginsberg and look
you know there are lots of clergymen who
are visiting the sets maybe one of them
whispered in his ear that you might want
to or Nordlinger might want to check out
this really fabulous source of great
tales about Moses and the burning of the
the bush and the Ten Commandments but
I've never seen anything archival II and
I've gone through the DeMille papers
that would uncover his Eureka moment but
i think it's sort of in the air among
the learner
people yeah identify what portions
armagh traffic the question is has
anybody done a detailed textual analysis
of the screenplay which by the way you
can find in the library of congress
which is where i saw and try to
determine line by line the various
layers of illusion and where he gets his
sources from not that I know and I'm
certainly not equipped to do it but
what's clear to me is that it is a very
layered text and then he draws from all
over the place and that very often he
does have his way with the text he
claims very forthrightly that he's not
messing but if you know some of the
names in our household one of the what's
her name that Yoko Bell the character of
your head who's tell me who was that
again I'm blanking Moses's wife well
birth mother something an important
biblical character jazz a beautiful name
you have it and he calls her in the film
yoga bell and we have an aunt you have
it and we always thought it was
hilarious that she could also be called
yo ho bell very funny so he makes up a
lot of names he makes up scenarios maybe
that's the Midrash calling I don't know
but he does take liberties with the text
except he's steadfast and insisting that
they're not liberties their translations
so thank you for your talk about the
stone yes the Mormons believe that some
of the Lost Tribes of Israel he came to
America so a mark us a marker so I was
wondering if that man was just playing
along I think it's a very good point
that the Mormons lots of folks at this
time so an antebellum America are
thinking about the Ten Lost Tribes
theory there's a gentleman in New York
who's been very widely written about
noorda hi Noah who is actually an
official in New York who published very
actively about the Ten Lost Tribes is
one of these I'd
is that galvanizes the imagination
what's new in this particular case is
the notion that the tent command that
the Ten Lost Tribes actually brought
with them the Ten Commandments or
fashioned their own version of the Ten
Commandments once they were in America
so that's an interesting wrinkle but
clearly it's in that site Geist of the
19th century especially on the part of
people who are very eager to find a very
an ancient pedigree for this country I
already spoke once but your question
about the Midrash reminds me that there
is there is a place where I could
recognize where it says will be DeMille
quoted Philo and because my my eyes were
very alert to any any presence of that
philosopher in the movie and it's at the
burning bush scene when Moses and I
think Joshua is actually with Moses at
that scene which is not really biblical
I think and either Josie through Joshua
Moses says about the encounter that you
have had an encounter with eternal mind
and I'm sure that's not in the book of
Exodus but eternal mind with being Philo
and I remember thinking later as I
thought back on the movie that he really
did use that source so here's a job for
you in your spare time you can go
through the movie and pick out those
portions that are from Philo or Midrash
or other forms of biblical exegesis or
just straight out of de Milles
imagination alright yes right here I
think thank you about the stone and
given the fact that it is the Ten
Commandment after living out slavery
this was any discussion because it is a
time of this the civil war etc how this
is in participation Ohio yeah the the
question questioner asked very smartly
given that they're given the site guys
the larger climate and the Ten
Commandments was there any discussion a
discourse at the time about
out the relationship of this fine to
slavery not at the time but I would say
20 or 30 years ago a group of scholars
taking another look at the wirework
stone we're advancing the argument that
and I can't do justice to the complexity
of the arguments I'm not even going to
try but they adduced of some kind of an
internal notion that the wire work to do
was really all about making it clear
that slavery was no good for the nation
and that they were going to then use the
Ten Commandments the stone as kind of a
proof text that very well maybe I don't
know but there's nothing at the time in
all of the sources that I took a look at
that would give rise to that particular
theory but you know we historians are
really good about predicting the past
and coming up with new interpretation so
it may very well be I don't know all
right on what's really fascinating is
that in the 1880s a very reputable
newspaper put forward the suggestion
that it was high time in American
culture for the Ten Commandments to be
aerated and ventilated I'm not sure that
happened in the 1880s but it happened
tonight so I thank you very much for
allowing me to aerate and ventilate the
Ten Commandments thank you